- It's mine, and it's
beautiful, and it's amazing.
(whoosh)
(hinges creaking)
(soft music)
- I actually grew up
in the Virgin Islands,
so I went to school in St. Thomas,
and in high school, good hair
was anything that was fine.
Curly texture is something
that was manageable,
bouncy, straight,
something that was easy to
maintain, that was considered good hair.
- Growing up in Atlanta,
everybody had a relaxer.
I don't remember seeing
anybody that had natural hair.
There were a lot of kids
that, you know, wore braids
and things like that,
but I still believe that
the relaxing process
happened before the braids.
- I always kept it really short.
And, I would have friends that said
it felt like pubic hair.
For a long time I thought
my hair was really ugly.
- When I was young, for
a guy, good hair was
a low cut, you know, even,
Caesar, number one, maybe you had
the part with the Nike sign on the back.
A little bit of flavor,
but pretty much everyone
had a low cut for the most part.
- Everyone had straight
hair, that was just the look.
Even if that wasn't their natural hair,
your hair, if it took you
five hours to straighten it,
you were gonna straighten it, because
that's what was acceptable.
- I grew up being into, like, punk rock,
and the skateboarding scene.
If you look at all the
cool skaters, and you look
at those hairstyles at the time,
it was all spikes, Mohawks,
fauxhawks, and my hair could never do it.
I kept it buzzed.
Everyone would say, every
time I would get a haircut
is like, why are you
cutting these curls off?
And I was just like, I can't stand them.
- My hair history can be best
characterized by control.
Trying to gel it down,
brush it down, put it into braids.
- My mom is black, and my dad is white,
and my mom had a really demanding job and,
would be gone by the time
I'd wake up most days.
And, so it would be left to
my dad, taking care of my hair
in the morning, and it was a total wreck.
I remember going to school
with so much hair mayonnaise
in my hair that it looked gray.
- Growing up, good hair, and
what I thought good hair was,
and what I was also taught,
from I guess, from, a little
bit of my surroundings,
my family and some friends,
was that good hair was when
you permed your hair, you know.
So, when I was growing up, I
did perm my hair a few times.
- Growing up my hair was really short.
It was like, low on the
top, skin on the side.
That's the way my mom liked it.
She said it was like, neat, clean.
- In our society, I think
hair represents a way
to express your beauty.
Individually, it can be a way
that you express who you are,
and how you're feeling that
day, but it's also a way
in our society, to kind of control
your aspects of beauty, and
I was always told
growing up that your hair
was supposed to be straight.
I didn't have that perfect hair,
therefore I was othered by society, just,
with the hair that I have.
- Perfect hair, good hair,
when I was younger came from,
when I used to watch TV,
or magazines or films,
all of the hair would
be long and straight.
And, even when I was
looking at black women,
on TV, they would always have
relaxed hair, or long hair.
They'd be light-skinned, beautiful women,
with equally beautiful hair
that was only beautiful
because it was straight.
- My father, he, growing up, and seeing
what he's seen, I mean,
I feel like there's just
this culture there that
it's like you have to
be groomed, and kept,
and you can't let what,
pretty much is you grow out.
Because, I don't know, it's seen as,
almost wild.
- It was reinforced through
the images we saw on TV.
It was reinforced through
the popular people in school,
the people guys wanted to date.
You know, you saw that
manifest itself in many ways,
and, I think today it still rears
its ugly head in many cases.
- I feel like straight hair
is only considered good hair,
because that's all you see.
It's all you see on ads, it's
all you see on billboards,
it's all you see on television.
You don't see, really
people that look like me,
and when you do, their hair's straight.
- Trying to date with
natural hair was definitely
a challenge, because I would
get the guy that was like,
oh, I'd love your hair
if it was straighter,
or you'd be more beautiful
if your hair was straight.
Or if I wear my Afro
just like, washed and go,
they'd be like, what is that?
So I think there's a lot
of different elements that
make us feel less secure
or less confident about
wearing our natural hair.
- People have made assumptions
by looking at my hair
that I smoke, I'm a Rasta,
I listen to Bob Marley.
Like, those assumptions are frustrating.
- I committed to having longer hair
right around the time the
Trayvon Martin case happened.
When the verdict came out,
I was just kind of like,
it really doesn't matter, like,
how acceptable you look to someone else,
so you should just look however you want,
what makes you feel comfortable.
And I think there was a strong
push for just, natural hair.
I really wanted to like,
embrace that, and embrace
the natural curls of my hair.
- I definitely think that
part of the reason I went back
to curly was the natural hair movement,
because when I Japanese
straightened my hair,
all that was really at
my disposal was gels,
and mousses, and things of that nature,
which, I felt, was causing
a lot of thinning for me,
and, didn't really give me,
like, the look that I wanted.
Whereas now, there are
pomades, there are leave-in
treatments, there are sea salt sprays,
like there are so many different
things that I can use now.
- I have a 16-month old daughter, and,
her hair is identical to mine, and,
I tell her, her dad tells her
how beautiful her hair is.
It's thick, and it's full,
and it's long for her age.
It's important that she
sees a reflection of herself
in me, so, that is another reason why,
you know, I'm really
adamant, and will continue
to stay natural, because
I want her to see herself
in me, and others around her.
I have friends and family
members who went natural
after having kids, just for that example.
And, I want to make sure that
I'm showing and expressing
and illustrating that,
natural hair is beautiful.
- I think my hair
has taught me, in this society and world,
to just be unapologetic.
People are gonna love it,
and then people are gonna fucking hate it.
People are gonna see you as
unprofessional sometimes,
and people are gonna have all these ideas
in their heads about whether, and,
like what kind of person you are.
- I feel like my hair
has taught me about the
importance of confidence
and individuality.
I fell like black women's
hair is political,
but is also not, in that,
it will always be,
in certain professional settings,
if you have big in Afro,
that then may be a problem,
or, that you'll go into certain spaces,
and people will try and touch your hair,
will say something
derogatory about your hair.
- I often think that my hair
came out of a lot of
unwanted struggle.
Like that sense that,
nobody loves you, you're useless,
you don't have any contribute, and like,
my hair is kind of like,
that reclaiming of like,
nah girl, like, I'm here to take up space,
you're gonna look at me, like it or not,
and most of you are gonna love it.
- I think in America, and
living in our society,
a lot of people tell you what is normal
for your hair.
In the eighties, you wanted to
have big, frizzy, curly hair.
Trends change with your
hair, and the only way to,
I think to truly be happy with your hair,
is to embrace what works for you,
to find what works for you.
And for me, my hair represented who I was,
and my personality, and as I grew older,
I got more comfortable with my body,
and got more comfortable
with who I was as a person,
and I wanted my hair to reflect that.
- Your hair is beautiful.
I've lived the straight hair life.
It was cool, but, I think that the way
that you are naturally will always
be more beautiful.
I think you shine more when
you're your natural self.
- My hair just taught me to
embrace myself, to love me,
the way that I came, the
way that I was created,
and, the way that I am,
right here, raw and all.
It's not bad to appreciate other cultures,
but, it's also good to embrace my own.
And that's what my hair has taught me.
- I'm just so happy that girls nowadays
have different kinds of
role models to look up to.
And I think it's also important that
you can be versatile.
One of the fun things I
love about my hair is that,
tomorrow, I could wake up being like,
I really want it to be straight.
And, I can make it straight.
So, it doesn't have to be any
one thing from day to day,
year to year, or throughout your life.
People are constantly
changing and evolving,
and, we're allowed to do that.
- I would say find your tribe.
Find your group, and it
wasn't until I found my pack
of strong, independent people
that embraced their curls
that I felt like, oh, I
could run with these people,
because they are me.
- I think now, good hair
is whatever you want.
Whatever makes you feel
the best when you walk
out the house, is good hair.
For me, this is good hair for me.
And for someone else
it might be a low cut.
Whatever, when you walk out
the house, you feel like
you're on point, you feel like
your confidence is booming.
That's good hair.
(upbeat music)
(whoosh)
(hinges creaking)